Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and hopefully
by now you guys have all had a chance to see
the game of thrones comic con panel and the
new character video they released. It’s
pretty much all the characters I talked about
way back in my season 5 characters video.
But when I did that, those were just rumors.
It’s basically the Martells and a few other
big characters. They did recast Myrcella,
but they recast actors every year. This video
is going to be mostly about the people they
didn’t announce. Like Arianne Martell, the
Greyjoy Uncles and Young Griff.
In case you’re just finding me for the first
time I’m doing weekly game of thrones videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I
even have a weekly book giveaway going.
I’ll announce the winner of that at the
end of this.
So full disclosure on the castings: just because
certain people weren’t cast it’s not confirmation
their parts of the story have been cut entirely,
as long as we hear about them before December
they still have a chance of making it into
season 5. The Child of the Forest was one
of the last casting announcements last year.
That confirmation didn’t come till November
13th and she was in the finale.
So if Arianne, Young Griff or anyone else
not in that casting video squeezes there way
into season 5. They have to do it by around
that time.
Some of you are asking who exactly is Arianne
Martell and why is she such a big deal?
In the books she is Prince Doran’s oldest
child and his heir. Without giving away book
spoilers. She has a very ambitious plan to
seek revenge for Oberyn’s Death. A lot of
that plays out in A Feast for Crows, the story
of Season 5 on the show will largely draw
from books 4 and 5.
Book 4 features a lot of Arianne, so to cut
her out of the show completely it would mean
cutting out a whole big side plot. I’ll
explain in greater detail how the show might
do this when I get to spoilers. It’s possible
for them to do book 4 and cut her out, it
would just be a big disappointment. Arianne
is also a big character in Winds of Winter,
so the show would have an even harder time
dealing with future things she does that Martin
hasn’t written yet.
It’s the same story for Young Griff. If
you’ve read the books, just use spoiler
tags when talking about him. If the show completely
cuts him out it would also mean cutting out
anything he does in future books. As weird
as that sounds I actually thought they would
cut him out after watching the season 4 finale.
This is where we need to reference the Comic
Con panel. It got a little weird for anyone
that hasn’t watched it yet. Dan and Dave
were a little weird. George RR Martin was
a little weird and there was some behind the
scenes weirdness going on. All because of
these huge changes.
What does that mean?
George RR Martin has always been very open
about the show existing in an alternate universe
from his books. He’s not happy or mad about
Dan and Dave changing things, he just acknowledges
that it’s a thing and the changes are only
going to get more pronounced.
If this worries you, just forget about it.
Remember, alternate universe. It’s like
the DC Comics TV Shows and the movies. Separate
characters even though they all flow from
the same source material. Batman on TV is
not the Batman Ben Affleck is playing.
So just so we can talk about Arianne specifically
and Young Griff we need to get into book spoilers.
Again, I think the show won’t end up doing
anything here. But just in case spoiler warning
for those two characters.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, everybody ready.
Here we go.
Arianne is a surprising omission because she’s
like this big influence off to the side of
the Prince Doran. His plan is what people
usually refer to as the Dornish Master Plan.
I won’t talk about that here just because
the show will definitely do that, we can discuss
it more in a future spoiler video.
Arianne has her own plan to take down the
Lannisters. Speaking of which, she has some
pretty awesome sex scenes with Arys Oakheart
the kingsguard Tyrion sent to guard Myrcella
when the Martells took her in.
Without getting too specific let’s just
call the Arianne plot the Myrcella Plot. Which
goes horribly until Prince Doran reveals his
master plan to everyone.
I’m so much more excited about that after
learning they cast Alexander Siddig as Doran.
All I’m going to be thinking is Doctor Bashir
with his super smart genetically enhanced
brain pulling the strings of this epic plot
in Westeros.
It seems like based on the castings, the show
will just streamline things and they’ll
just go straight to the Dornish Master plan.
No Myrcella side plot.
I guess I can deal with that, I’m a little
worried about Winds of Winter stuff they’ll
have to skip. But since that book isn’t
out we can’t speculate on that yet.
It’s like Arianne’s big moment comes and
goes in book 4. So cutting her out means they
get to cut out a bunch of stuff. Including
the Darkstar.
There is some confirmation this is what’s
happening. In the casting announcements. It
lists Trystane as Prince Doran’s heir. Not
Arianne.
And what about Young Griff. Not even a misdirect
casting announcement. Sometimes when shows
cast big characters and they want to keep
it a secret, they list alternate character
names. Like on Arrow when they cast Brandon
Routh as The Atom. They used the Blue Beetle’s
name on the casting sheet. Just so comic book
readers wouldn’t figure it out and spoil
it.
I don’t remember Game of Thrones ever doing
this. The Child of the Forest was kind of
a secret casting last year. Not secret, they
just waited til way late in the year to do
it and didn’t publicly announce it. It wasn’t
a secret.
Because of where Tyrion is in his story, if
he were going to run into Jon Connington and
Young Griff. He would do it in the first half
of the season. Meaning, they’d be shooting
those scenes right now and they’d have had
to have cast actors in those roles.
Since they haven’t announced anyone, I think
the show is going to cut them out. And just
like with Prince Doran and the Dornish Master
Plan. The Show is going to streamline Tyrion’s
story and take him straight to the eastern
continent.
I don’t want to get too deep into Tyrion
spoilers or anything, but if you’ve read
the books. I think he’ll just get to where
he is right now a lot faster. Just imagine
all that Young griff stuff not happening.
The issue with that is there’s a whole army
of people you’d have to cut out, including
the Golden Company. So it’s possible the
show could just never mention any of those
people again.
I am hoping that they just give Quentyn Martell’s
story to Trystane.
Okay, spoilers over. Back to
confirmed castings. The Sand Snakes, the High
Sparrow, Yezzan. What is the show going to
do with them?
Let’s look at what happened last year. All
of the characters that they put in the casting
video last year and in the season 3 casting
video ended up having major parts. So everyone
in this season 5 video will get a lot of scenes.
There were minor characters like Mark Gatiss
that didn’t make it into a video. He only
ended up having a very small part, so it’s
likely that anyone else they cast between
now and November will have a super small part.
The biggest changes are mostly locations.
Season 5 will revolve around King’s Landing,
The Wall, Braavos, Meereen and now Dorne.
How much time will we spend in the new places
like Braavos and Dorne? Probably not as much
as you want.
Remember, there’s only 10 episodes, and
arguably Jon Snow, the the Lannisters in Kings
Landing and Daenerys are the biggest characters.
Don’t be surprised if we only see a truncated
Arya story and the same situation in Dorne.
Part of me feels like with the way Dan and
Dave are streamlining characters and plots,
most of the final players in that final season,
whatever that ends up being. Are people we’ve
already met. There will always be new characters
they’ll bring on, but I feel like the main
characters now, will be the main characters
in the series finale. That’s just the way
TV works.
In the books who knows, I think the character
arrangements will change a lot. But the show,
will be way more predictable. Or a better
way to think about it is the show will be
way easier to follow.
Let me know what you think about all these
characters being cut out. Do you think they’ll
just magically appear later in the story or
do you think big ones like Arianne and Young
Griff are gone for good?
I’m thinking the later but we won’t be
able to confirm till the end of the year.
Just to make you guys happier, here’s the
winner’s of last week’s giveaway. I had
a book giveaway and a comic con giveaway going
at the same time.
Congratulations to Kinetic Vibe and Blunderbuss.
You win the funko pop figures and Sarah Gennaro,
you win the book. I’ll message you guys
on your channels for details. So be sure to
check your inboxes.
My next game of thrones video will probably
just be for the High Sparrow or the Martells
we will see. I’ll post that next week.
In the meantime click here to learn all about
the golden company and click here to learn
all about the blackfyre rebellion.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!